[Music]
in philip k dick's to android's dream of
electric sheep mercer and mercerism play
a completely central role in the
culture of human beings on earth at that
time and it's also one way to
differentiate
human beings apart from androids because
androids can't take part in the fusion
but human beings including specials like
isidore
are able to do so and find incredible
you know
solace and meaning in this as well
partaking in it through empathy boxes so
when buster friendly places mercerism
in his sights it's going to provoke some
very important reactions and
realizations and we find that
you know buster friendly
is somebody who not only does everybody
listen to quite often or at least many
people do but isidore particularly likes
him john isadore the special but
he says something about buster friendly
irritated him one specific thing
in subtle almost inconspicuous ways
buster ridiculed the empathy boxes
associated with mercerism not once but
many times he was in fact doing it right
now
no rock knicks on me buster prattled
away to amanda werner and if i'm going
up the side of a mountain i want a
couple of bottles of budweiser beer
along the studio audience laughed and
isidor heard a sprinkling of hand claps
and all reveal my carefully documented
expose from up there that expose coming
exactly 10 hours from now and then a
little bit later on uh isidore says
maybe buster is jealous that would
explain it he and wilbur mercer are in
competition but but for what our minds
is the door decided they're fighting for
control of our psychic selves the
empathy box on one hand and buster's
guffaws and off-the-cuff jibes on the
others i'll have to tell hannibal stoke
that's his boss that ask him if it's
true
he'll know now
who is buster friendly
we'll find out later
chris the android says
that he's one of us
right and
this could be true or it
you know could be false
um we're not really
quite quite sure
right um priss is talking about you know
the empathy boxes and stuff like that
and um
then
irimgard breaks in so pris says i don't
think this will end the cult of mercer
this is after the expose but right this
minute there's a lot of unhappy human
beings to isidor we've waited for months
we all knew it was coming this pitch of
busters she hesitated and then said
well why not buster's one of us
an android erum guard explained and no
one knows no humans i mean
now is this really the case
i mean people are suspecting
something even somebody who's mentally
regressed like isidore
is able to
think things through right so there's
this this very
interesting uh part here here we go
buster friendly's odd show like the tv
version continued 23 unbroken warm hours
a day the additional one hour being a
religious sign off 10 minutes of silence
then a religious sign on again
and
he says to himself here we go
women like amanda varaner never made
movies never appeared in plays they
lived out their queer beautiful lives as
guests on buster's unending show
appearing isidor had once calculated as
much as 70 hours a week how
did buster friendly find time to tape
both his
odd and vig vid shows isadore wondered
how did amanda verner find time to be a
guest every day month after month year
after year how did they keep talking
they never repeated themselves not so
far as he could determine their remarks
always witty always knew weren't
rehearsed amanda's hairs glowed her eyes
glinted her teeth shown she never ran
down never became tired never found
herself at a loss
as to a clever rhetoric to buster's bang
bang strip of quips jokes and sharp
observations
so how was this going on it's clearly
beyond
normal human capacities right and so
the boss slot actually has some ideas
about this
as well
isidore says to him i think buster
friendly and mercerism are fighting for
control of our psychic souls if so slot
said buster is winning he's winning now
isadore said but ultimately he'll lose
slo raised his head
why because wilbur mercer is always
renewed he's eternal at the top of the
hill he's struck down he sinks into the
tomb world but he rises inevitably and
us with him so we're eternal too he felt
good speaking so well usually around mr
stout he stammered
sloat said buster is immortal like
mercer there's no difference
and
israel says how can he be how can that
be he's a man sloth says i don't know
but it's true they never admitted it of
course and then he says is that how
buster friendly can do 46 hours of show
a day that's right sload said what about
amanda werner and those other women
they're immortal too
are they a superior life form from
another system
and slot says i've never been able to
determine that for sure as i have
conclusively in the case of wilbur
mercer
and then he goes on to to deal with the
the cat that they've brought in and it
breaks off so we've got a couple
possibilities
who is buster friendly is he an android
as pris and armaguard are going to
say a little bit later on is he some
sort of human but doing something beyond
total human capacities or is he some
sort of alien life form from another
place which is immortal
all of this is going to be in some
respects
besides the point as we find out when
the expose begins
um it's it's uh talked about the very
end of
chapter 17
where um
rachel wants the radio on to hear it but
then we actually hear it narrated at the
same time as the androids are
dismembering the spider
in isidore's apartment and so
here we go in the living room buster
friendly on the tv screen said
take a look at this enlargement of a
section of background this is the sky
you usually see i'll have earl parameter
head of my research staff explain in
their virtually world shaking discovery
to you and so what is it going to be
well
they begin with the set
so
what's going on there
blow ups of the video pictures a new
voice from the tv said when subjected to
rigorous laboratory scrutiny
revealed that the gray backdrop of sky
and daytime moon against which mercer
moves is not only not terran
it is artificial
very important distinction there
artificial
how
well
the tv set continued the moon is painted
in the enlargements one of which you see
now on your screen brush strokes show
there's even some evidence that the
scraggly weeds and dismal sterile soil
perhaps even the stones hurled at mercer
by unseen alleged parties are equally
faked it is quite possible the stones
are made of soft plastic causing no
authentic wounds in other words buster
friendly broke in wilbur mercer is not
suffering at all so the set
the plot what what it is the scene
is fake
then the research chief says we managed
to track down a former hollywood special
effects manager wade cortot who flatly
states from his years of experience that
the figure of mercer could very well be
some bit player marching across the
sound stage quartet has gone so far as
to declare he recognizes the stage as
one used by a now out of business minor
movie maker with whom quartet had
various dealings several decades ago
so according to core top buster friendly
said there can virtually be no doubt now
notice at this point the kind of case
they're they're making well we got a guy
who says that this looks like a movie
set that he was on a couple decades ago
and you know that's painted so the
mercer thing is is fake too right now
this is actually a a weak argument up to
this point
and you know buster friendly there is
possible doubt at this point
but
the research
chief says we spent a good deal of time
examining publicity pictures of bit
players once employed by the now defunct
hollywood movie industry
we located by means of thousands and
thousands of photographs a very old man
now named al jerry who played a number
of bit parts in pre-war films from our
lab we sent a team to jerry's home in
east harmony indiana i'll let one of the
members of that team describe
what he sound and then a new voice comes
in the house on lark avenue in east
harmony is tottering and shabbat and at
the edge of town where no one except
algeria still lives invited amiably in
and seated at the stale smelling
muldering kipple filled living room i
scanned by telepathic means the blurred
deep debris cluttered and hazy mind of
algeria seated across from me
i found the old man did in actuality
make a series of short 15-minute video
forms of films for an employer who he
never met and as we'd theorized the
rocks did consist of rubber like plastic
the blood shed was ketchup and the only
suffering mr jerry underwent was having
to go an entire day without a shot of
whiskey so now
it's moved from well could be kind of
maybe plausible to
we've got the smoking gun we've got the
actor al jerry who admits that
he did these uh
vignettes
for
somebody we're not quite sure who
and um you know
there was no actual
pain or suffering and then um
buster friendly clinches it he says al
jerry
well well an old man who even in his
prime never amounted to anything which
either he or ourselves could respect
algeria made a repetitious and dull film
a series of them in fact for whom he
knew not and does not
to this day
it has often been said by adherents of
the experience of mercerism that william
wilbur mercer is not a human being
that he is in fact an archetypal
superior entity perhaps from another
star well
in a sense this contention has been
proven correct
wilbur mercer is not human
does not in fact exist the world in
which he climbs is a cheap hollywood
commonplace soundstage which vanished
into kippel years ago and who has
spawned this hoax on the saul system
think about that for a minute folks so
he's laid out what's what's going on you
know it's it's a sound it's a set uh
there's a scene there's an actor it's
all fake none of it was real there is no
such thing as mercer mercer is not
suffering in any of this and so this
raises the question
what is going on with these human beings
that are gripping these empathy box
things and seeing the mercer vignettes
and
being there with all these other people
sharing not only memories and
perceptions and physical violence done
to their bodies
but also their moods their emotions
all this stuff what's going on in this
fusion
that androids themselves can't partake
in and so
buster friendly comes to his conclusion
mercerism is not just false
mercerism
is a
swindle
he says we can we can't fathom the
peculiar purpose behind the swindle yes
folk swindle mercerism is a swindle and
he says
what is it that mercerism does
well if we're to believe its
practitioners experience fuses men and
women throughout the sol system into a
single single entity now is it a single
entity or not if we look at the other
parts we see that maybe that's not the
case
but what we do uh see is that they are
all together in one
consciousness together one one you know
empathizing
whatever we want to call it set of
relations and so friendly says
maybe somebody could use this for
nefarious purposes he says
an ambitious politically minded would-be
hitler could and so he's suggesting that
but interestingly the androids there in
uh isidore's apartment draw a different
conclusion this is actually something to
help separate out
human beings who can participate in this
or at least think they can maybe it's
all fake right
from the androids who can't really make
sense of it
empathetically though they can
understand cognitively how important it
is for human beings maybe this is a way
of being discriminatory
towards androids to maintaining a false
division between the
human
and the
android she says without the mercer
experience we just have your word that
this empathy business this shared group
thing
and then she says how's the spider so
it's interesting because she's showing
her very lack of empathy at the very
same time that she's saying yeah maybe
this empathy thing is overrated and
mercer at the heart of it is all a fraud
now
does the revelation
that mercerism is a swindle and mercer
himself is going to say yes it's false
it you know all these these things that
buster friendly are pointing out is true
does that change anything and the answer
strangely enough
is no and so we have two really
interesting
encounters with mercer after this
revelation first isidore his apartment
is breaking down into kipple and he says
um you know
mercerism isn't finished something ailed
the three androids something terrible
made the spider he thought maybe it had
been the last spider on earth and the
spider is gone mercer is gone and you
know everything starts breaking down he
grabs the
empathy box uh you know but he's also
descending into
the tomb world
so we see uh irimgar beatty says he's
breaking everything what's he doing and
he says i'm not doing it
and
everything within the apartment starts
breaking down
he says it's happening to me again i'll
be down here a long time it's always
long a dry wind rustled around him the
heaps of bones broke even the wind
destroys them at this stage just before
time ceases i wish i could remember how
to climb up from here he says mercer
where are you now this is the tomb world
and i'm in it again but this time
you're not here too he's been
abandoned
and then
he says um here we go something crept
across his foot
the mutilated spider advancing itself
haltingly on its surviving legs the
spider who he drowned in order to put it
out of its misery he picked it up and
held it in the palm of his hands the
bones have reversed themselves the
spider is again alive mercer must be
near
and so he says
come here to mercer
and he cries mercer and then mercer
shows up and he says
is the sky painted are there really
brush strokes that show up under
magnification
yes said mercer i can't see them you're
too close mercer said you have to be a
long way off the way the androids are
they have a better perspective
is that why they claim you're a fraud
i am a fraud mercer said they're sincere
their research is genuine from their
standpoint i am an elderly retired bit
player named al jerry all of it their
disclosure is true they interviewed me
at my home as they claim i told them
whatever they wanted to know
which was everything including about the
whiskey mercer smiled it was true they
did a good job and from their standpoint
buster friendly's disclosure was
convincing they will have trouble
understanding why nothing has changed
because you're still here
and i'm still here mercer indicated with
a sweep of the hand the barren rising
hillside the familiar place i lifted you
from the tomb world below just now and i
will continue to lift you
until you lose interest and want to quit
but you will have to stop searching for
me
because i will never stop searching for
you then there's a funny little aside i
didn't like that about the whiskey
isadora said that's lowering
mercer responds that's because you're a
highly moral person i'm not
i don't judge
not even myself
before i forget it there's something of
yours here he opens his fingers
on his hand rested the mutilated spider
but with its snipped off legs restored
and so
what is uh isadorf discovering that yes
it can all be
fake and yet mercer is still there with
them and the
empathy experience is still possible and
miracles of a sort can still happen
what about deckard
mercer does something very different
with deckard
he's already talked to him before
and said you know it's the nature of
life that you have to violate your
identity
and there are some things that you need
to do
mercer is is going to face the three
remaining androids a figure in the
shadows waited if you move i'll retire
you rick said the male one waiting for
him i'm not on android the figure said
my name is mercer
and so
rick says am i outside mercerism now
because isidore had told him that he was
and mercer tells him
no
mr isidor spoke for himself not for me
what you're doing has to be done i said
that already
and then he imparts information
to deckart that is going to essentially
save his life
and allow him to kill the killers to
fulfill his uh
you know mission of destroying these
androids and he tells her
he tells him
one of them is behind you and below not
in the apartment it will be the hard one
of the three and you must retire it
first quick mr deckard on the steps and
this is where priss attacks priss who
looks like rachel rosen and deckard does
that and then he goes on to kill the
other two androids the two
babies
after all of this happens rick
drives
on his own to a place where
nobody else is
right
a cluttered hillside swooped up at him
he lifted the hover car as the world
came close
uh he talks to you know tries to talk to
dave holden
and um
you know discusses uh
what's going on and then
here we go
he hung up the air had a foul quality he
rolled up the window again dave is
really out he reflected i wonder why
they didn't get me
the car had become too cold now so he
opened the door and stepped out a
noxious unexpected wind filtered through
his clothes and he began to walk
and he walks up
on the hillside in which each step the
weight on him grew too tired he thought
to climb stopping he wiped stinging
sweat from his eyes salt tears produced
by his skin his whole aching body then
angry at himself he spat spat with wrath
and contempt for himself with utter hate
on the barren ground then he resumed his
trudge up the slope the lonely and
unfamiliar terrain remote from
everything nothing lived here except
himself and he's thinking to himself and
then
at that moment the first rock
and it was not rubber or soft foam
plastic struck him
and the pain the first knowledge of
absolute isolation and suffering touched
him throughout in its undisguised actual
form he halted then goaded on the goat
invisible but real he resumed his climb
rolling upward like the stones i'm doing
what stones do without volition mercer
he said panting in front of him
distinguished a shadowy figure wilbur
mercer is that you
my god he realized it's my shadow
i have to get out of here down off this
hill why because in the mercer story he
goes up the hill gets hit with a lot of
rocks gets up to the top and then the
killers kill him right so rick is saying
oh i don't want that now what what has
happened here what's going on
he has identified now
with mercer and as
when he's talking to miss marston
she says mr deckard you look awful so
tired and your cheek is bleeding you
look like wilbur mercer and he says
i am i'm will wilbur mercer i've
permanently fused with him and i can't
unfuse i'm sitting here waiting to
unfuse somewhere near the oregon border
you know and he says a little bit later
it's strange i had the absolute utter
complete real illusion i'd become mercer
and people were lobbing rocks at me but
not the way you experience it when you
hold the handles of an empathy box when
you use an empathy box you feel your
with mercer
the difference is i wasn't with anyone
i was alone so this is something a bit
different at this point but he's able to
get out of it and then
we get to the very
end of this discussion
with something that rick deckard says
she says to him they're saying now that
mercer is a fake his response
mercer isn't a fake
unless
reality
is a fake
so there's a sort of
bedrock that we hit here
with what's left of mercer after all the
other stuff has been revealed or peeled
away there's still
something
going on that is at the very center
of at least rick deckard's experience
now and which
potentially is so for others and we see
that
the revelation of mercerism as a swindle
as mercer himself
and you know says to isidore has changed
nothing
you